uh people are saying you have an amazing
surprisingly Donald Trump impression and
they wanted to see if you could teach
Bobby how to do the Donald Trump
impression you try first no you go first
well just give me a sentence that he
would say and then I maybe I'll try
greatest country in the world is America
okay it's
terrible was terrible that was terrible
that was like Marlon BR so you got to do
the easiest way to do Trump is like the
speech Trump when he's doing a rally
Trump okay okay cuz it's just in the
back of your throat the greatest
country the greatest country okay a
little bit the greatest
country the greatest
country the best country the best
country wow what a country wow what a
country a lot of Asians a lot of a lot
of Asians maybe too many maybe too
many